how's it going oh is that you sniffing
and s you sniffing so glad I miss you
when you're always the game sorry I
always get that mixed up hello sniff is
Newburg
let me shoot you with my cutter I find
it a little weird that I don't have to
actually shoot inside his nose I just
have to shoot on this side I mean video
games they don't make sense these days
back in my day I made sense
I bet whoa we teleport into a basket
that should make sense appears to be a
piston that's we were smashing with our
hatchet except it's not hard to say that
because it right anyhow we're gonna talk
to wait let me think here think so I'm
so Swedish these days my pronunciation
whatever let's do it seriously I'm not
terribly musical but a musical that's
you that's how I sing I can see that why
not do something about it yeah why not
excuse for doing nothing
reminds me of the asylum I'm a little
confused but that would summarize his
game pretty good actually so that's the
bottle fish a somewhere alcohol I would
assume I was a pine up I don't need no
we're not going there today breath
alright well it is a cat Akita can't
even cooter that is [ __ ] creepy I
guess we're gonna kill it so I wasn't
allowed to make jokes about one
direction but hey I'm too tired to give
a [ __ ] seriously and I said something
about Jonas Brothers and someone when I
can
what did i do they try to kill me that's
what they [ __ ] trying to do get out of
here I don't know their names
Jonas brother number 3 the fast one that
I don't understand why they're famous
the tickle pit I gotta take out steer ok
ok get me get me get me come on catch me
catch me I'm on my period that's right
you're gonna [ __ ] a woman on her period
just don't do that you got the Big Mama
left
oh let it's one that action what are you
doing here well they were easy to
dispose of put a little bitty bitty
bitty bitty play opens on its own that's
how I have as I do drum be the same shut
up fishy shut up shut up some points on
sides are bouncing some points on some
point soap on top
whoa oh my god it's an octopus how you
doing
no don't hit my watts get out my web man
you can't hurt hey wow did you not hear
what I just had games never listen
lesson of life how dare you
there we go some point until serpent
that's how music goes musicals threw
bottles everyone knows that [ __ ] I
didn't actually know that I feel
indulged holy Sh a / holy chaperone I
know I know
of course of course in your fully
functional that's what I we're doing
here right Bros we're doing the walkers
ID we need to do three times and this is
last one I can't I can never [ __ ]
finish doing it but I will try my best
I will try my baby this is I hate those
big ones
idiot time how long I'll not try we did
it half I push you didn't really like
high-fiving no J that's okay with me you
know what I'm not gonna argue period of
time there we go we got all the
instruments violin those are not
violence those are cell celos cellos
chalice this it's cellos right you're
Italian
you know those things
surely not lost perhaps mislaid I
suppose good job you carry the chinga
that'll be right
you know cello beyond law cello there
you go all right the game is asking me
if I'm ready so I guess I am
oh no oh no this is like Atari hello all
over again
goddammit you seem to have lost your
rhythm I didn't do [ __ ] hideout it
where's your confident Dallas where's
your confident okay so we played guitar
hero and Alice without confidence it's
supposed to go in here whoa what is this
oh I don't know about this one brass
should we do it should be seriously I
don't know go mission yay nice smoke one
day you'll be joining them family vault
I imagine yes know what I'm talking
about yeah yeah what just [ __ ] happen
to the frame oh the bed comes down yay
gentle um oh you just interrupted my
dream I'm so L after the show I suppose
it's not the monster from SCP it is it
only is no okay
we're just rolling with this this game
should be called Alice let's just roll
with it it's all kinds of crazy [ __ ] I
long I should have this empty she if
Alice doesn't do anything she started
doing okay whatever it basically means
down approach Alice she will [ __ ] you
what and out in a good way
oh no well I guess we're going to bed
too huh no drunk Alice any clues update
to one different don't over their teeth
whatever is that it there's no bridge no
nothing what about not them don't where
did that SP monster go
what if we jump on the boobs we will
find yeah I will pry the find out
jumping on boobs solves a lot of things
it's really underrated if you think
about it don't think about it too much
there is a bed here oh no oh no Westlife
and sink justin bieber one direction
they're all coming at once what do I do
oh [ __ ] right in my left titty oh [ __ ]
Thanks hi manhoods our thing it really
are ow
not my right kitty Oh No be gentle to me
and think I'm on my period they're extra
sunset heaven god damn yo let me break
your Florence and face I don't my
dissing vincible in this mode Lauer do I
do more damage to I do more damage I do
more damage cool so amazed at last Jamie
me hate me don't you nursing that song
how dare you Alice is not listened to JB
oh it's another soupy monster
oh sorry to wake you up
that is [ __ ] creepy man of course we
do a star that's tough
this star this star we need the star
apparently for some reason and I haven't
quite figured out yet but I think Alice
Alice did you have an idea Alice what is
this Alice Alice I'm not even I'm not
even controlling you guys swear to God
okay I was not fair but I shouldn't lie
to you okay
drunk Alice ideas anyone know do you
have any nope well tool-free whoa whoa
whoa there was a drunk ideas written on
that wall and Omega Oh mister okay good
Alice good good for you
as a female sir with a wig this posta
Felicia it's ruined if I can't put it
back together carpenter will grind my
path grind her pearls I think we both
know what that actually means okay
I like our way Louis so if I understood
this correctly collect the four blocks
surrounding there to start the challenge
oh it's a puzzle I love these type of
puzzles is it only me do you like these
puzzles do you I like them I think they
can it's sweet so walrus is a pimp and
these SP monsters are the HOS that's
what I got from those that's what I got
from this game let's see what he says I
see the proper order of things is often
a mystery to me you too you too uh we
collected one girl hold your horses
woman you will have to wait like
everyone else okay
we're going here uh wait
pickles pickles penny go hey don't tell
me what I put my bunny woman goken it
tickles can i improve my Ken robots or
cry robots or whatever if I want them to
last longer
you see the explosive fast kids these
days they grew up Y became a butterfly
what the [ __ ] do you call a [ __ ]
go come on collect that gas yeah bro
five shut up
quick the voice actors of this game oh
man
okay oh there's a bridge over there
let's go I think we can do it right here
yes
brah fibers uh what do we got
yes son
talk to person Pullman's at a distance
where they may be easily forgot
good good good on you bro whatever do
now okay we got all the ones we got here
we just needs four more or a fire more
or whatever the [ __ ] I don't probable
that is this bad as a fish we need three
more um oh we can operate something now
cool finally whoa that's right now
yeah it looks pimp as hell man how do we
get up there oh great job fellas I
became a butterfly come on we can do
this I believe in myself enough to yes
Bravo I became a butterfly Oh someone
should do like a count how many pom it
you call that jumping right it's alright
let's just grab it how does it quick
shut up please
because your voice acting makes me want
to kill something which is actually a
good thing in this game now that I think
about it alright we came from here the
crab was up there what do I do woman
you're so beautiful I can't ah oh here's
something
oh I can't evaporate on this [ __ ]
actually I can't I have no idea what I'm
doing
whoa that's how you do it yeah [ __ ]
I made a lot of us commented on last
video drunk Alice you're my favorite of
all how would that thing on her but
there it is okay cool that thing on her
back looked like one of those things
that I come out of there oh oh oh now we
can do it how does it work
where'd you get paid I don't know I
guess we're gonna find out I feel like
that one is correct that one needs to go
there how do we do it how do we move
things okay
ah what annoying controls uh ah there we
go and that was way too easy
come on I told you I liked those fossils
to something like I'm literally mentally
challenged at most things but some
puzzles I'm actually okay with let's
just say okay